all people of good faith agree that what
happened to George Floyd was heinous and
depraved it was murder but that's not
what we're seeing on our violent streets
we're not seeing outrage really
expressed about that and that's not what
the criminals and the domestic
terrorists are perpetrating as they use
mr. Floyd's killing to try to murder
America earlier in the day Floyd's own
brother issued a call for peace if I'm
not over here messing up my community
nothing because that's not gonna bring
my brother back at all it may feel good
for the moment just like when you drink
but when they come down you got one you
won't wonder what to do but this isn't
what an Tifa wants or cares about and
it's not what other radical elements
want they want war they want to tear
down what took us almost 250 years to
build literally and figuratively the
president tonight reaffirmed his duty to
defend the Constitution my first and
highest duty as president is to defend
our great country and the American
people I swore an oath to uphold the
laws of our nation and that is exactly
what I will do now New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo whose nursing homes became
Kovan killing fields said he's not going
to seek and doesn't want the president's
health I was shocked at the force they
used to move the protesters who could
not have been more peaceful calling out
the American military for a photo
opportunity these are young people who
still have idealism and want to make
this nation better and that's a good
instinct and it should be encouraged it
should be encouraged we've been showing
footage all night of what they're doing
throughout Manhattan and by the way what
we saw some of what we saw is what I saw
last night up close and personal in
Washington
DC the protest wasn't very focused on
the heinous injustice committed against
George Floyd yet there were a few signs
and there were a few George Floyd
t-shirts worn but there were no
candlelight vigils there was no singing
and embracing people were taking selfies
in front of Secret Service agents whom
they were mocking and swearing at and in
some cases spitting it I'm not sure what
any of that accomplished but the violent
and vengeful elements were focused on
creating chaos terror and fear across
America so don't you dare lie to the
American people by saying that any of
this had anything to do in its violent
core with George Floyd from what his
family says George was not that kind of
person
he wouldn't do what these people are
doing tonight peaceful protests are
usually held as I said to Hannity during
the day after all we know that because
under the dark of night under the cover
of darkness we can't see who's throwing
what who's starting what fires like the
one that I saw as we were leaving the
scene at the historic st. John Church
now we walked to the car seeing these
historic hotels beautiful buildings
boarded up graffiti everywhere I felt
like I was back in Iraq in 2006 and
February except I actually felt a lot
safer on the streets of Baghdad then I
did at times in DC last night now the
aim of these criminal enterprises
including an Tifa but not limited to an
tyfa is to undermine confidence in our
institutions of government at all levels
local state and federal these wanton
acts of violence are part of a
coordinated effort to eventually
overthrow the United States government
its well-funded and its well-organized
on social media no Twitter warning is by
the way from jack dorsey even though
they seek nothing short of an overthrow
of all that we love and believe in an
elimination of our constitution
basically all of our rights including
the Second Amendment
much of the first don't care about
George Floyd they're using and abusing
his memory to create more suffering and
more chaos it's like one giant video
game to some of these folks but their
call to duty is one of annihilation of
the country that we all love now where
did this all come from I was thinking
about this today and talking to friends
and and and down the road and in DC you
know where did it come from why is there
so much hate the American people and law
enforcement officers are overwhelmingly
good people it goes way beyond anger
over the tragedies of Floyd and Trayvon
Martin and falando Casteel the genesis
of this seething hatred began decades
ago at our universities and it spread
like a contagion into all levels of
learning radical professors attacking
the ideals of Western civilization and
it's only gotten worse yesterday check
this out one professor at the University
of Alabama provided a tutorial on
Twitter about how to pull down national
monuments and guess what the tweet by
Professor Sarah Parcak
is still up on Twitter Jack Dorsey
claims Trump's tweets are encouraging
violence this woman is a professor and
she's getting paid with the tax dollars
that the University of Alabama gets and
by the way universities are teaming with
America hating indoctrinate errs like
her and not only we should will she not
get fired for that she'll probably get
an award at the next faculty meeting the
finest colleges in the nation are
producing America hating agents
provocateur like this aggrieved
Princeton and NYU Law School grad Colin
furred mattis
he was allegedly behind the wheel of a
tan minivan as his passenger fellow
attorney in Fordham Law School grad
ulraj Rahman when she threw a Molotov
cocktail into a police cruiser hateful
anti-american poison is also
in some of our churches as well who can
forget Obama's pal Reverend Jeremiah
Wright's us of KKK rant but ultimately
this all comes from us the people how
are we parenting our kids are we
teaching them to love and respect
everyone no matter what race no matter
what ethnicity our fathers on the scene
at all are we teaching our children to
love or hate America are we teaching
them basic right from wrong don't take
anything that's not yours even a penny
when we don't teach the light of God's
love we risk that our children in our
country get sucked into the darkness
eventually and that's what you're seeing
play out tonight now I can't imagine
that anyone with a brain or half a one
would want to get mixed up with this
crowd look at them their pretend
privilege soldiers who would melt if
forced to defend themselves ultimately
this is where strong leaders emerge to
lead people away from the lawlessness
away from the darkness yet today blue
state mayors and governors have failed
to act to contain the madness afraid to
do so would be politically incorrect or
somehow portray an alliance with
President Trump this is not about
President Trump this is about America
preserving her and some media figures by
the way have aided and abetted the chaos
portraying those driving the lawlessness
is somehow justified in smashing
grabbing pushing beating destroying and
yes ultimately killing they hope the
spirit of this country they're portrayed
like modern-day Freedom Riders violating
curfews and taunting National Guardsmen
should be celebrated apparently in some
media outlets these news anchors that's
what you want to call them they're
taking sides with anarchists that's how
much they hate President Trump and
ultimately the old normal as they seek
to replace it with I don't know what
some type of new normal that's going to
be great
chi-ching they're willing to have the
country burn out of their obsession with
removing Trump from office well that's
not gonna happen
Americans are loving people but they've
had enough they've had enough of
lockdowns and now they've had enough of
lootings it's time to defend our
founding principles life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness we do this with
respect for our fellow man with our love
of God and our belief in the inherent
goodness of mankind and that's the angle